toute une semaine d'information sur la
santé mentale à partir de lundi prochain
martinique bonjour mes dix doigts
bonjour vous êtes un psychiatre membre
de l'association tombolo qui oeuvrent
dans ce secteur
on va commencer si vous le permettez
monsieur à toi on va commencer par défi
définir la santé mentale une nuance peut
être à faire avec les maladies mentales
d'entrée tout à fait la santé mentale en
fait l'un c'est un concept assez assez
assez vaste mais pour le simplifier en
fait c'est simplement doha mais ce qui
la définit en étant enfin et qui est
finalement un état simplement un état de
bien-être à dire ça ça assure pas ça
dépasse la question toute simple de la
maladie montagne c'est à dire que si je
suis addict aux jeux vidéo que je passe
20 heures sur 24 devant ma console et
que je me sens heureux je suis pas du
tout atteint d'une quelconque maladie
mentale europe osce a aussi un heureux
pour toi mais est-ce que cela n'a pas en
fait à entraver tinta liberté parce que
la maladie mentale la maladie elle
montre comment la définit en fait c'est
un sa'a procure une souffrance
significative et ça on traite un tas
liberté lorsque tu me dis 20 heures sur
24 à ces sujets bien si je suis heureux
parce que je suis avec mes potes à
travers le monde grâce à la à gaza
internet
si tu es heureux si tu le dis pourquoi
pas ouais alors comment là se pose la
question du diagnostic embarque comme
ben et habite au conte et souffrant par
exemple tu l'as dit souffrent ainsi la
souffrance manifeste au niveau d'un don
de ton corps de ton esprit de tes
émotions ça te procure une détresse un
particulière détresse personnelle et des
traits auprès de tes proches détresse au
niveau social également au niveau
professionnel c'est réellement une
détresse
ça va entraver finalement ta liberté
d'agir la liberté d'aller et venir
d'alim et ça ça procès à partir de là
que nous allons définir ce qu'est une
une maladie et non pas moi qui vais dire
untel personne ne se comporte
non pas que moi je ne souhaite ou que la
société le souhaite mais que son
comportement lui procure en fait de la
détresse
alors qui doit déclencher le processus
ce sont les proches et la famille
comment ça se passe alors là en est on
s'éloigne un peu de la santé mentale là
on est là tu m'a amené vers à ce qui est
finalement la maladie mentale la maladie
mentale qui procura c'est un vaste débat
ça dépend de quelle pathologie parce
qu'il ya certaines affections où je suis
conscient que je vais mal donc je vais
moi même demander de l'aide mais il ya
certaines tout le registre passons des
psychoses les psychoses c'est que je je
je je ne suis plus conscient de ce qui
se passe j'ai un comportement qui est
désorganisée une pastèque et d'orgues d
organiser ça me procure sert de la
souffrance c'est pour ça que j'essaie un
peu de me défendre si quelqu'un qui se
sent persécuté poursuivi pour chasser
ben il va naturellement se défendre
alors que en fait ce sont des
hallucinations qui vend qui vont
alimenter ses peurs là donc je vais je
vais avoir un comportement de défense
qui va essayer en fait de tenter de
l'amener à de l'amener vers vers le soin
ce sont ceux qui sont proches de lui
ceux qui se font du souci pour lui
et sinon si on n'arrive pas ben ça sera
les autorités comme ça arrive souvent
c'est soit le maire soit les flics
soient liés à la santé mentale
on y retourne qui pas de situation en
martinique
aussi c'est là qu'ils les la dernière
étude je pense sur la santé mentale
c'était en 2001 2014 il n'y a pas de ya
pas de dossier familia particulier en
temps en aidant les chiffres les
chiffres nationaux c'est à dire que la
santé mentale c'est une personne sur
quatre qui un jour ou une autre de sa
vie
petit fait honorable par rapport
parce qu'ils
qui existe dans le coup en métropole sur
les structures d'accueil et donc et
d'accompagnement existent hélas beaucoup
en martinique beaucoup bah ça dépend de
ce que ce que vous entendez par beaucoup
c'est à dire que nous sommes dotés à des
sommes une population de 385 milles
personnes est ce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons les infrastructures on voit
répondre à la souffrance pour ce type de
population à ce que nous avons en fait
un nid d un engagement citoyen aussi
aussi dense que qu'ailleurs la question
est là tandis que les structures
existent mais les structures dans toutes
les villes de france et de navarre
sentant sont en souffrance on l'a vu un
dernièrement à en psychiatrie ya eu il
ya eu avant même le mouvement des gis
les jeunes une mobilisation assez assez
massive pour dire que les moyens
manquent et que les que des structures
étaient a été assez assez assez dépassé
par da par l'évolution de la société
parce qu en psychiatrie ce qui ce qui
prime ce ne sont pas les techniques 1,6
mais ce n'est pas les outils ce soir
plutôt le rapport humain être présent
avec quelqu'un ce n'est pas comme être
lui offrir un service technique
est ce qu'on doit par lasser de cette
sortie bord vers la martinique pas trop
pour pas trop pourquoi parce qu on a hot
on est gêné on éprouve une honte parce
que justement parce qu'on devient
peut-être plus égoïste au sein de la
société
je suis désolé je suis passé à ses
experts pour le dire mais je le vis au
quotidien as je pense que il y a une
part de d'une évolution de la société
qui fait que c'est à chacun à chacun
pour soi et la maladie mentale reste
quand même quelque chose d'assez d'assez
en tant que personne ne veut en parler
exemple j'en profite pour lancer à pour
l'ancien une info l'un prochainement
rabobank
on va mettre en place ici en martinez
pour la première fois un programme dédié
aux familles c'est pro famille c'est un
programme psychoéducatif pour que les
familles puissent être
accompagnés dans la compréhension de ce
qu'est la schizophrénie ça extrêmement
spécifique ça c'est un programme bien
bien bien bien bien documenté et notre
crainte en fait c'est que des familles
ne s'engage pas parce que c'est vraiment
ça nécessite allemande une barre dans l
engagement un engagement fort des
familles c'est un programme de ce temps
et de tout ce temps c'est un programme
une fois par semaine pendant 14 semaines
ensuite il ya des rappels aux six mois
et 12 mois et 2 ans alors mes 10 ha soit
on m'a dit vous êtes médecin et
psychiatre et vous ouvrez au sein d'une
association association ton boulot alors
qu'est ce qu'elles apportent elles cette
association apporte en bouleau est né en
fait d'une inconstant le constat du dû
vite combien d'associations dans le
champ de la santé mentale ici en
martinique
très peu et même ceux qui existent ne se
ne sont pas interconnectés entre elles
donc nous avons décidé nous n'attendons
pas que des structures ou que les où les
instances intuit et l'air aux fins offre
de 2,2 les outils pour la prise en
charge de la souffrance psychique ainsi
en martinique en séance et un groupe de
soignants est d'usagé en créer cette
association là pour accompagner
justement avait personne dans le dos au
quotidien et justement ouvrait pour la
déstigmatisation ce que tu viens de dire
la la la honte de déclarer que j'ai une
maladie mentale ou l'imaginaire à
l'imaginaire collectif qui dit que si
j'ai une maladie mentale c'est que je
suis un raté finalement un handicapé à
vie
alors cette semaine de la sortie brutale
qui qui va commencer d'or de 24 carats
twitter ça va se décliner à l'ère du
numérique et l'air d'être là tout
changer dans quelle source
c'est justement dans le lien finalement
pascal un train avant disait c'était
l'amour qui soit l'amour qui soigne et
ce avec le lien qui soigne lorsque nous
sommes avec un individu on dit souvent
il a besoin de 2,2 de parler donc en
reste ils ont discuté en avant on
palabre est en fait sous un arbre
aujourd'hui on palabre à travers les
réseaux à les réseaux sociaux qui rend
quasiment bouleversé bouleversé les
lélés les mentalités et tu as un
territoire au début tu dis moi je suis
addict et je passe maintenant 20 heures
sur 24 derrière mon ordi à jouer à
ouroux jeux en ligne ben ça c'est c'est
internet qui a créé c'est une nouvelle
pathologie finalement le fait de rester
coincé derrière son équipe je veux je
peux dire ça m'a permis de multiplier
les choses avec des jo à l'autre bout de
la planète au siège aussi au 1 bd jean
mais de manière manière virtuelle mais
avant il y avait aussi un leurre au
niveau des deux de la radio tous les
gens qui faisait de la cie bio qui peut
être existé mais c'était pas aussi
étendue qu'aujourd'hui un jeune gamin de
13 14 ans il est il y peut être
connectée à bien il ya des systèmes de
réseaux quoi alors internet a permis de
multiplier de 2,2 les contacts de
d'échanger des informations ça c'est
dire aussi ça c'est super intéressant
c'est à dire que il ya du bon et du
mauvais essentiellement beaucoup plus de
bons que de mauvais à partir d'internet
on peut justement à tisser densifier un
réseau et toucher une large en une large
population en donnant de l'information
de l'information juste parce qu'on peut
trouver aussi du bon et du mauvais dans
ce qu'on tape une information sur google
tapez schizophrénie vous allez avoir des
milliers de deux de données qui viennent
et certaines ne sont pas tout à fait un
tout à fait juste est-ce que je peux me
permettre une question plus personnelle
mais une falaise bazois vous êtes
d'origine algérienne êtes en martinique
dans ce secteur grâce à martiniquais
illustre au frantz fanon absolument
absolument mais hélas en fait ce qui me
rappelle en arrivant j'avais dit je suis
en pélérinage psychiatrique le gars qui
m'entendent et simply 4 qui n'avait
absolument pas compris un vieux
psychiatre en martinique qui en plus est
qui qui n'avait absolument pas compris
là
la petite boutade en fait la petite à
petit en fait c'était je suis un peu
déçu c'est que finalement un fan on n'a
pas rester très très longtemps ici je
mets un peu la pub a failli confiance et
ça le dernier livre / / / fans ans qu'il
a merveilleusement des crimes il a
décrit non pas ici en martinique mais la
main puis son passage ici été bref
bon peut-être que mon passage sur un
prêt ici aussi dans la retenue ou pas
comme quoi françois nour a quand même
permis ces connexions entre l'algérie la
martinique merci docteur mais 10 ha soit
on rappelle que vous êtes un médecin
psychiatre que vous étiez avec nous ce
matin à l'occasion de la semaine
d'information sur la santé mentale
merci d'avoir été dans son caddie bonne
merci à vous
[Musique]